[Music]
hi I'm Cameron balahan senior product
manager at Google Cloud
and I'm Aaron wongiola a Java developer
advocate here at Google Cloud
in this session we're here to tell you
five reasons why Java apps are better on
Google Cloud let's get started let's do
it
[Music]
the last few years have been an exciting
time to be a Java developer
there are compelling new language
features to incorporate and some new
practices around building and testing
that provide tangible new capabilities
but it's not always clear how to go
about adopting these advancements
especially if you're also working on
adapting to cloud computing in general
that's why today we're here to go
through five reasons why your job apps
are better off on Google Cloud
we'll start by discussing deployment
methods and how Cloud run makes it so
simple to deploy services that scale
right back down to zero whether you're
deploying from Source or have specific
needs for your containers
Cloud run is a fully managed container
based hosting platform that lets you
build and deploy code written in any
language
for certain languages Java included
Cloud run also supports building from
source which will build the containers
from build packs for you
now our sample app for today will be a
straightforward spring boot web service
so we'll start by curling it from
start.spring.io
unzipping it and opening it in the cloud
shell editor
once we have our sample open we'll add a
sign of life to our app to help us
decide if it's working properly after
deployment
at this point we are ready for an
initial deploy
now when considering where to run my
code I prefer to ask which solution
involves the least infrastructure
management to meet my needs
and if I know that I want an entire web
service rather than just handling a few
endpoints or events then my first stop
is generally Cloud run
to get started with that simply run
gcloud run deploy from your Source
directory
and that's really it that's all you need
to access source deploys
you'll be prompted to supply The Source
directory region and enable the
necessary apis to complete the deploy if
you didn't add it on the command line
now on the other hand if you decide that
your app needs to be built with a
particular Builder or you want specific
steps to be taken before building and
deploying such as running your tests
then you have to define a
cloudbuild.yaml to inform Cloud build
about your needs
this allows you to specify things like
running tests with the build tool of
choice
tagging the resulting images or
configuring the machine family that
cloud build will use
and much more
now one useful practice to ensure that a
release will be stable is to direct a
portion of your production traffic to
the new version for a period of time
before completing the full release
this practice is called Canary releases
and in my experience it's often seemed
compelling but also too labor intensive
to be easily adopted
this sort of release pattern can require
significant experience when managed
manually but thanks to Cloud Run's
traffic splitting feature it's well
within reach for teams of any size
traffic can be controlled through the
console or command line for both new and
existing revisions
to do a canary release we can simply
deploy a new version of our service and
configure it to serve an appropriate
percentage of our traffic
be sure to leave the canary running for
a reasonably long time to gather usage
data and allow the build to reveal any
possible issues
once we're confident that our Canary
version is stable we can adjust it to
serve the rest of our traffic and the
release is complete
now Switching gears to a specific
optimization that's especially relevant
for serverless Java apps let's talk
about Native image compilation
now let's imagine that this service that
we're working on is only used
infrequently so Cloud run often scales
it down to zero after a brief idle time
about 15 minutes
now after scaling down to zero the first
user to make a request will need to wait
for a container to start up before they
can be served
this is a common issue in serverless
Computing known as cold starts
and one traditional solution is to keep
a minimum number of instances running at
all times
now another Java specific option which
can be far more cost effective is native
image compilation which can dramatically
reduce the start times of your
applications as you can see here we have
a cloud run service that was deployed
regularly and natively and a cold start
in each reveals a significant benefit
now where Java apps are typically turned
into byte code at compile time and then
interpreted into native code at runtime
this allows you to compile directly to
Native executable at compile time
with Native image compilation you're
effectively cutting out the jvm entirely
trading off its versatility for active
artifact size and speed at runtime
we've spoken about this optimization
earlier this year both at i o and on our
blog and its role in improving your
organization's Cloud economics
that is the practice of getting the most
out of your existing Cloud resources
this optimization is Again by no means a
silver bullet but I see it as an
important tool for teams to understand
and have at hand especially when they're
considering serverless use cases
which is why I was so excited to share
earlier this year that our client
libraries now support native image
compilation out of the box
which minimizes the configuration
required if you decide to use it in your
apps
now I'd like to continue on from there
and get a little bit more Hands-On with
some specific advice for people who are
adopting native image compilation
one tip to further reduce the startup
time and size of your app is to remove
any and all unnecessary code from the
class path because anything that's
discoverable will be added to the closed
World conception
spring has offered some handy
configurations for doing this with some
of their own modules like spell the
spring expression language module and
XML support
another thing that often needs tweaking
is the set of classes you'd like to
initialize at build time versus runtime
and as a final quality of life tip when
working on Native images let's discuss
running the compiler in quick build mode
as we've discussed earlier native image
compilation can take a significant
amount of time think a few minutes
so ideally we wouldn't have to wait for
an entire compilation cycle to test each
change in our artifacts When developing
essentially quick build mode tells the
compiler to use fewer optimizations so
the time between you making a change to
your native image and being able to test
it is minimized
as we can see the difference is
significant especially if we're doing
hundreds of these builds per day either
locally or on a test server
now on the topic of security you now
have the ability to cryptographically
sign your builds using binary
authorization
enabling these deploy time security
controls is easy in Cloud run you can
simply navigate to your Cloud run
service on the console
go to the details Tab and click enable
next to the binary authorization
enforcement section
binary authorization will enable you to
implement proactive container Security
in your build processes which is an
important step towards improving overall
build security
you can set up specific attestations to
ensure that a required activity has
taken place on every image that you
deploy like for example a vulnerability
scan
and finally I'd like to bring out my
colleague Cameron to share some exciting
news with us
thank you Aaron I'm Cameron product
manager at Google Cloud as Aaron said
we're committed to making Google Cloud
the best cloud for Java developers that
includes the products and Integrations
you just saw and extends even further to
your core Java tools and even your
runtime to that end I'm pleased to
announce that Google has joined the
eclipse adoption working group a
Consortium of leaders in the Java
community and makers of The Tamarind
build of openjdk Tamarin is one of the
world's most popular jdk distributions
certified by adoptium for heightened
compatibility and security testing as a
member of adoptium Google will make
Tamron available across gcp products and
services providing Java customers the
highest standard of Enterprise security
and more opportunities to create
Integrated Security focused Solutions
we're excited for you to try it out
thanks and back to you Aaron thanks
Cameron
now we've covered a lot of ground so how
about a bit of a recap
we started from scratch by building and
deploying an app from source to Cloud
run and then decided that we may need a
bit more control over how the container
is built so we showed a cloud build yaml
that would help you do that and then we
implemented an advanced deployment
pattern a canary release thanks to Cloud
run traffic splitting feature
and then we described how build how to
build confidence and security of your
artifacts through signed and attested
builds with binary authorization
and finally we had our exciting
announcement from Cameron around the
adopting working group and how Tamarind
can help us to secure our apps all the
way from the jdk to production
thanks so much for joining us enjoy the
rest of your day
[Music]